the new Lord of the Rings movies
announced by Warner Brothers do we like
this idea or hate it and more
importantly will it succeed welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and move your
Channel
[Music]
so first of all thanks to sources that I
have that work in and around the
industry they have confirmed to me that
Peter Jackson will be involved in the
new movies Warner Brothers are planning
what's happening
in fact he has to be involved with any
new project that Warner Brothers develop
because of the contract he had from the
previous movies so hopefully this means
we might get to see something with a bit
of integrity
because right now we actually have no
idea what they're planning it really
could end up being anything is it going
to be a remake is it going to be a
reboot is it going to be some sort of
side project or something that's
happening in the background or God knows
we just don't know yet is it going to be
based on something like the salamerian
stories or something like that
I don't know but what we know right now
officially is that Warner Brothers
through this other company own the
rights the film rights to the Lord of
the Rings and The Hobbit and that
they're talking about creating a series
of fresh movies based in and around that
now this is all very strange nobody
really was expecting it but it's
happening and it will probably make a
crapload of money but
the Amazon rings of power that we'll
talk about in a second hasn't been
massively popular with the Lord of the
Rings fans mainly because Peter Jackson
wasn't involved now it's my
understanding again actually that Peter
Jackson actually couldn't be involved
but Amazon never wanted him to be anyway
but again because of these existing
contracts it might have been a little
bit difficult but either way Amazon
never even reached out as far as we know
so that kind of irritated a lot of fans
and made a lot of fans nervous from the
get-go
this project though will have Peter
Jackson attached and a lot of the movie
fans of Lord of the Rings will insist
upon it and it will reassure a lot of
them what role Peter Jackson has might
not be as reassuring though because
apparently there is no guarantee that he
will get to be in charge this time write
it direct it etc etc just that he will
have to have some sort of involvement
it'll probably be an executive producer
role as a minimum
um and then go from there it will very
much depend on how conversations go the
contract pretty much only says he has to
be involved it doesn't say specifically
how and apparently that's quite a common
sort of addendum to a lot of these
contracts when a director writer goes
into a big franchise series with a
studio because they then want to be
involved and have some element of
control over what happens next
so will these new movies be a success I
think yes it probably will I think the
Lord of the Rings just works better on
the cinema screen than it does on a
television screen I mean Amazon had to
spend all of those hundreds of millions
of dollars to even get the Lord of the
Rings to look like it did and let's be
honest it was beautiful but a few of the
special effects were a little dodgy and
maybe some of the battle scenes Etc that
we've seen up to now weren't as Grand in
scale as we were hoping I just think it
works better on the a big scale I think
Peter Jackson understands these stories
better than Amazon do and I think he
understands what the fans want from the
series so for me
Peter Jackson's involvement is
absolutely vital and like I say
Warner Brothers have seen what's
happened with Amazon they've been
watching the social media they will
already know that actually the initial
reaction from a lot of Lord of the Rings
fans to this news that they're going to
be doing another movie is negative I'm
not exactly full of maybe the excitement
they were hoping so getting Peter
Jackson's name attached to this as
quickly as humanly possible is
absolutely vital for them because they
want to sort of nip any negativity in
the bud as quickly as possible and let's
be honest there are a lot of YouTube
channels and a lot of people out there
influencers Etc that thrive on
negativity that's what they live for
that's how they get views and how they
get clicks because at the end of the day
you can have a hundred good news stories
but people really for some reason seem
to enjoy the bad news story more and
seem to click on it they seem to enjoy
in some ways the negativity and the
drama
if something's just lovely and going
ahead nicely and everything's easy
people get a little bored but if
something's hard and full of drama and
tension and I don't know it seems a
little bit more exciting
so there are people out there that are
going to jump on this and be as negative
as they can be it'll be a woke pile of
crap before it's even been written so
we're just gonna have to accept that but
Warner Brothers are definitely going to
want to avoid as much of it as possible
I'm getting Peter Jackson on board we'll
do that
so Peter Jackson will be involved in
this he will whatever his role is we'll
have to find out soon but I fully expect
Peter Jackson to be front and center and
to be talking a lot about this over the
next couple of years while we're waiting
for whatever it is they actually make to
get done and he will be the face of the
project and it'll make the job of the
hate clickers a lot harder have an in
front and center
so guys get in the comments tell me
exactly what you think is this a project
you're looking forward to and having
Peter Jackson on board does that make
you a little less nervous about whatever
it is they're going to produce does
Peter Jackson make this an exciting
project gentle comes to tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really saved and as
always if you enjoy the content and you
want to support the channel a little bit
more consider hitting that join button
there's also a bunch of links in the
description for everything Sidetrack
Facebook page Twitter Discord blah blah
blah blah please go check those out as
well as always please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]